洗濯バサミ
果たして洗濯バサミは高速ドリルに耐えられるのか
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
先日とあるガチャガチャをしてきました
なんか前も一回やったんですけども
意味不明な物ばっかり出たので
そのリベンジというかね
似たような匂いを感じたガチャがあったので
今回そちらをやってきました
今回はこちら
ゲスなおもちゃガチを
やっていこ...（？）
ガチャをやっていこうと思います
ゲスな商品が出てきます
何が出てくるかわかりません
なかにあるもの全部やってきました
来た　来た！！
ゲスな商品か...
ゲスな商品って言われるとなんなんだろうね...
ゲスな商品って言うからには
とてもゲスなのかなーと思って
ちょっと買ってみました
ゲスっていう表現に関しては我々はまだ
ちょっと曖昧なところにあるこの
我々ホモサピエンスはね
今回このヒューマニティ全般において
このゲスという言葉の定義をね
はっきりさせようと思うよ
では開けていこう！
けっこうそこそこあるよ
まだ見ないようにしよう
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20
4000円?!  4000円...  4000円使ってんじゃん...
ではちょっと一個ずつ見ていきましょう
全20個でございます
見てもらってわかると思うんですけどサイズが結構みんなバラバラなんですよ
では順番に見ていきましょう
1個目
あ、これ知ってる
そしてこれ一瞬で壊れたねこれたぶん今
これ今壊れたねたぶん
ウサギドロップだ
ウサギドロップのキーホルダーでございま～す
ウサギドロップのことはよくわかんないんだけど
たぶんウサギドロップ好きな人からしたらとてもなんかいいんじゃないですか？
74円
これで行きます
なに？なにこれ？
スモールガーデンバケツ
フッ
まじか～
このサイズのバケツでございます
これいきましょう
まだ200円越えはねまだない気がします
なつかしい
寄生獣だ
寄生獣のパラサイトチャームらしいです
ほ～なるほどね
こんな感じですね
中に真一のミギーがいます
これはマジねコメントしづらい...
つぎこれいきます
うわ！！
く～これおれわかんないな
ガンダムGのレコンギスタ
クリムニックさんです
うわーー申し訳ない...
レコンギスタ見てないんだ～
次
おー
これはちょっと...うれしくはないけど
うわ！
キモくない？
なんかゲロはいてる猫のキーホルダーです
何でゲロ吐いてるし
誰にもいえない内緒ごとをあなたの変わりに内緒ではいてくれるお守り的なものらしいです
気持ち悪い
次
もうぱぱっと行きましょうほんとに
20個もあるからね
なにこれウゴウゴパンカってなに？
うわ！！まって
ハッ
これは失笑だわ...
ぷりぷり博士です
ただの下ネタですね
さよなら...
次
お！　お～
これは悪くない
カエルさんのフィギュアですね
うわ！なんかしっかりできててひょっとしてこれが一番まともか？
これは俺はありだと思います
次、次はおめぇだ!
お～
フェアリーテールの
ラミアスケールのキーホルダーです
すいませんフェアリーテール見てないんですよ～
次
やべえ..弱虫ペダルって書いてある
うわ！やべえ..弱虫ペダルも見てないんだよ～
寄生獣以外全部わかんないよ今のところ...
東堂くんです
自転車に乗ってますね～
次
なにこれ...なにこれなにこれ
アイドリング..アイドリン..アイドルの..アイドルのだ
これ押すやつだたぶん
（アイドリング23号伊藤祐奈です）
アイドリング23号伊藤祐奈です
(うんうん)
はい
あのね　（うんうん）　ぼくね　（うんうん）　きみのね　（うんうん）　名前を知りたいの　（祐奈だよ～）　大正解！
次
だいぶ昔のやつじゃない？
これ待って..だって...
まだだって卒業してるメンバーとか...
何で俺こんな詳しいんだ？
あ、さっきと同じ猫のシリーズです
売れなかったのでしょうか猫がゲロ吐いてるシリーズです
次
ダンガンロンパか～
超高校級のゲーマー千秋
どこかでみましたね...
寄生獣のやつです
次
てことはこれもひょっとしたら...
もうこのカプセルシリーズはまちがえな..ちがうよ！
ハイキューだ！
研磨君です
ハイキューは好きな人が多いからね
研磨君あたったよ～
ハイキューも見たことがありません
噛んだ
また猫のあれシリーズだ
次は血を吐いてますね
吐血している猫です..　ありがとうございま～す！
次
少女革命ウテナメタルグッズコレクション
私はバラの花嫁エンゲージした方の思うがままです...
姫宮アンシー
全体的に僕の好みと当てはまっておりません
次
よーし
もう名前も知らないこれに関しては
テンカイナイトってなに～？
百発百中のスナイパートリビュトン
次
さあ、いよいよ3つになってきました
あ、これかわいいよ
あ、これはちょっとあたり臭がするぞ
何でこれすごいあたり臭がする
あたりっぽいです
かっこいい犬
あと2つです
残り2つとも似たような感じじゃね？
ちょっと2ついっきに開けましょう
怪しげなかばんが2つ入ってました
こいつはたのしみだな
はんこセットだね～
チクショー
ただですねすみっこぐらしのかわいいシールがついてきたのでこれはよしとしましょう